hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to west of loathing now
we're back in dirt water because we're
tracking down a few other things before
we get back on that train I think we
just need one more item and it's some
kind of yarn I don't know where to get
it I don't know how to get it I don't
know what to do to get it but I'm gonna
find out but first I gotta go through
the various miscellaneous side quests
that I got going on here and then again
I just love this game so much so I'm
eager to squeeze every single moment out
of it possible even some of you aren't
well have you got my knife
yup here you go excellent this will work
a lot better than than that hammer I was
using okay I'm sorry
oh that's not that funny I used to have
this recipe for a C very secret jerk
sauce but my jerk friend Dave J stole it
from me and then he died and took the
secret to his grave literally I mean he
was buried with it you want me to dig up
his grave he's dead he won't mind okay
hand me that hammer that you were using
also where is he I do did you even tell
me where he was where where was his
grave wait where's his grave is it I
guess I know of many a cemetery but
before I do that I got I got a flip flap
around dirt water just a little bit more
to see if anybody else is here you're
not in the mood to talk okay all right
hey Lloyd need help with anything
everything's alright okay nevermind then
you guys are fine guest room is fine
everything's fine here so what what else
would possibly need to be here hello do
you find lovely day all right well just
meander on my way to the various
cemeteries that I know I doubt it would
be the petting cemetery so it's probably
reboot Hill because there's a lot of
stuff at reboot hill that I haven't done
yet that's right
Oh a pile of bones oh no buying
okay that's a tough pile of bones all
right there we go
d ly D not enough okay go go go go go
[Music]
don't worry sis pain oh yeah there was
some weird tree with the keyhole in it
wasn't there that was here right yeah
there's a key on the trunk of this key
so why is there something for that do I
need a key for that it doesn't even give
me the option for it but I suppose I
want to get a Kia
find out either way okay so I don't know
about you but there's multiple plots
here all right Shang Queens were
reasonably sure he's dead they got a
common ooh
dink scotch turkish n' drowned in a
whiskey barrel that's what he would have
wanted the ground here seems reasonably
soft oh I got whiskey oh that's nice I
thought I was gonna get a Skellington
old dead top took us kind of a long time
to get around to this Vince he was alive
for two it oh no he was dead for a while
and you just buried him later all right
Fred Deeks couldn't remember the rhyme
about which snakes are poisonous
ah Patton and medic grid genera blends
he died as he lived
screaming I screamed so much a net
jangled the first lady bicyclist to ride
off a cliff all right I got riding boots
these boots are made for riding but not
the kind you're riding you're probably
thinking of which kind of riding were
you thinking of I'm very confused here
lavender crinks inventor of the external
combustion ended engine it's the remains
of a picnic oh it's a gothic cameo and
it's an ornately covered carved brooch
with a jet-black gem in the center which
come to think of it might be jet black
because it is in fact a jet this item
goes on your lapel okay I don't need
that bow I don't need that spooky
resistance I mean maybe I will I'm in a
cemetery so who knows what's gonna be
spooking up around here also I just I
just might have remembered there might
have been a cemetery over in the other
plot but I'm gonna go through here first
this tombstone is big and fancy and as a
door in the front I open it inside
there's a document and a weird little
metal object read the document the
letter describes a ton Tyne the burial
wishes have chat bust early in a series
of centers sweet quince of letters but
till Victor bit-bit litter okay take the
object I got a key Oh
okay well I got a key fragment but I
don't know what but litterer means but
alright I got butch litter all right how
about this pick that lock inside the
tombstone is a document and a weird
little metal object oh yeah the document
describes a ton time the burial wishes
of Sam feathersmith and a sequence of
letters oh all right
the object got a key fragment what
pretty good
all right crack it well there you go
read that scribes at on time what's at
on time
the burial wishes of Phillip iron gloat
in the series of letters oh yeah do I
got to write those down because I don't
feel like we're I think I'm doing I mean
I could it be easy alright fine you're
really pulling the wool over my eyes I'm
already down god damn it uh I gotta go
find a pen all right I'm back my guy got
a pen and I got a [ __ ] piece of
paper that's actually an envelope on
here yeah so I'm gonna just just give me
one second I go get the documents back
up okay third third is oh yeah that's a
T why write it over there
I wrote it over on the lip you can't see
that but I really like on the the ledge
so I'm so goddamn stupid come on shut
the [ __ ] up brain and work right o HT
all right that's good handwriting yeah
helps if I can't read what I wrote [ __ ]
why don't I put I have a desk here why
don't I just put it on the desk and I
can wait
why didn't I just grab a normal why
don't I have normal paper I don't know
I'm stuck I am an adult I swear to god
I'm an adult [ __ ] right oh I HTE
this has been an ordeal but I got it
okay two more let's hope there is
horrifying as the first okay second does
that spell anything boo
Lila lay egg
good okay whatever I don't know stupid
what was the point of that not that go
away from that got a cool elsewhere now
there's nothing over there why did I
write all that down I got the key
fragments what am I doing with it all
right
assemble the key whoa a little spit a
little baling wire and voila a Tontine
key voila indeed okay so does that go to
the thing Xavier J horn hog ran for
mayor right off a cliff funny
lucky Vinnie Pike bound to run out
sooner or later ate too many wasps Oh
Gina slap radish no my slogan why didn't
you listen to me hazel batchly
embroidered herself to death that one
guy you know the one yeah him bred
Hagins the most strikingly rat-faced man
any of us have ever seen Stan Reata
Minkel stand tried to eat men did I try
to name all these people I feel like I
had a didn't this try to eat a live
Eagle on a dare ground ears relatively
soft oh good
looks like the Eagle not skeleton
doesn't seem particularly threatening
apart from being a general reminder of
your mortality hello who are you my
name's Bernard for Chi SHhhh
lower your voice they'll hear us who the
cultists Shh yes not a fan the
reanimating dead people's skeletons I
don't want to be reanimated sounds
horrible can you imagine having to walk
around without your skin on how
embarrassing not to mention the cold
well sure plus I mean dying's hard
enough who wants us to come back to life
just when you've got used to being dead
right I could see that please can you do
something let you know when it's safe
great all right cool where are they Sam
what are you talking about they overhear
their cultures can i Wimble Womble my
arm and leg over this way anybody hello
whoo that looks spooky all right okay
palette toots burry died of a disease we
don't have a name for yet ah
base
on the contents of the coffin you'd have
called it exploding skull syndrome / let
a Fink territorial scoffing Jim oh okay
all right well that's that's peculiar I
seem to have walked into a precarious
situation I'm a church board you're not
gonna get past this barrier whirling
bones without well making it so there's
no barrier of whirling bones ah I'm
gonna shoot them I'm gonna shoot those
bones try epistle and definitely shoot
the floating bones into pits that are
too small to flow nothing to it they
didn't even know what hit him
Suzanne Goin stripper come up with
buried with her treasured collection of
dog ears gross these cultists looks like
they're barely maintaining control over
that skeleton wait a while see what
happens you hide behind a tombstone and
wait after a few moments the skeleton
rests itself from the Cultus control and
goes on a rampage bones and teeth fly
everywhere and none of them belong to
the skeleton if that gives you any
indication of how the fight turns out
seemingly satisfied with the carnage it
is caused the skeleton crashes something
into the ground and scratches something
into the ground and then shovels off to
the south yikes well they're dead now
all right so cool grudge watch skeleton
this is what the skeleton room must be
its name Oh must be a black bookie
frightening topics in necks max ah
getting smarter about next max it means
being able to summon skeletons who were
smarter doing it what'd you say okay
well I'm gonna throw that into the hole
I'll do that eventually fed of room
nothing left but boots and teeth cheese
nothing in there but three bedrooms and
a single stale smell peninsula whackers
nice lady but a real fortune this is a
hastily constructed very shallow privy
investigate you open the door and dig
around in the Tetris sure I do you fight
a little square yellow paper you got a
night of sticky note this is a sticky
note with the magic word written on it
for security pack
practice alright this is security all
right what is it the note says
abra-cadaver that's got to be important
you stick the note into your journal I
should check that out
okay all right read that ley lines Elsa
branch oh I've got everything I need to
parently do that I didn't even know that
that was the thing that I could to get
right away my goodness I but I also got
a key so I'm gonna see you busy okay
Oh secret door opens in the side of the
tree there's a chest inside Tontine this
chest was hidden behind that secret door
what's a ton tine the hell is at on time
this chest contains a lone but extremely
large gemstone and a document above
describing at on time which you
apparently won despite not even signing
up for it once it dies at Ajanta an
unbreakable Roubaix oh so this is why
they form that taun time what's a table
time and what's with these letters I
have enough lol lol why what lol was
that I'm a right down low not that I
can't remember that but alright whatever
fine but she's alright so somewhere
around Hillstrom ranch but I'm not gonna
worry about that right now
maybe it's the Buffalo file I mean now
it makes me that is a very obvious place
to go but I also forgot there's a
freakin Dave yard
he said the guy's name was Dave I
thought of this like halfway through my
adventure in the cemetery and I'm not
just pulling that I'm on my ass but I'm
like I'm an ad the guy's name was Dave
it didn't hit me until way way later all
right Dave beat Dave see Dave Jay you
dig up the day Greg the grit the Dave
grave and pry open the Dave coffin
instead of a Dave corpse it contains a
garbage Dave strange you reach into the
garbage bag in a surprised to find that
it's pudding
now it's not just putting it's putting
in motor oil who would do this keep
digging you finally managed to reach all
the way to the bottom of the bag and
retrieve a sodden lump from the bottom
good thing I've been training for this
all my life you unclog the wad and dry
it off then wash your arm in a nearby
ditch it's better be worth it
Dave secret sauce recipe just combine
these ingredients in a small pot stir in
abra-cadaver rough hop hop how sure okay
all right we'll go with that one we're
going that's what that is that that is
okay sure all right and then off we go
wherever they'll we're actually supposed
to go this is definitely not helping me
in any capacity for the main quest but I
am all on board I don't even care uh
yeah I got it hey thanks a million buddy
now my slop will be world-famous here
let me give you a little something for
your trouble it fell in the slop but
it's still good oh my god it's probably
terrible it it's not that bad actually
oh look at me my sloppy toppy oh let me
put a snakeskin on that oh where is this
where the hell is my snakeskin I have no
there we go Electric snakeskin not what
I was going for a three dollar ATS that
pretty good to all stats that's that's
not bad at all but a cool snake three
democracy well I might as well get might
as well key at all if I had to put
anything on my sloppy toppy all right
cool that work did it work oh apply to
hat I got a press this button okay you
put the rainbow-colored snakeskin on
your hat and beam with pride okay now
I'm going to let me go to the Buffalo
pile because I'm pretty sure that I
didn't actually finish all my business
there after I broke everything else oh
no bang
well man Gary you really need to pick up
nards on this one because you're really
letting me down here I wish you wouldn't
do that
okay she led who get off to the Buffalo
pile and then hopefully in there like if
I had a guess
well I if I had to guess where a
necromancer's hideout would be it would
be in a giant pile of bones
pretty sure anyway buffalo Buffalo
buffalo yes so there's Oh
crotch crotch crotch crotch crotch
scrunch the Skellington crotch and this
is all still fuchsia I even asked the
developer about this when I was at PAX
West he said there's no way to get it
back so whatever the real thing was
unfortunately not for me not for me
can't do it what was here again fighting
this is just a fight right yeah it was
just a fight to Danny
whatta be bada boom boom well oh not bad
that shooting Andy got ups okay
splish-splash on you I gotta get going
come on I don't have time to fight
everybody and I don't wanna die or
anything you with this I'll shoot the
pile
bang okay Gary you get that one no hit
um ayah loser hurry up I don't have time
for this hang okay now you Gary hi yah
yah yah yah yah yah there we go Gary
Gary all right okay cool okay so is
there anything else here ooh leave the
shells alone right now oh that would
probably would be what I need to do if I
actually had the cushy douchey the bill
whatever the mixture would have been if
I hadn't done this stupid you know the
stupid that I was talking about yeah
it's stupid that's what I'm talking
about what is this what is this oh I
need that was a detailed diagram of one
of those Buffalo skeleton human
skeletons hybrid things are making a
handful coins that didn't help me god
damn it scary stuff
chanting shuffling of robes clattering
of bones scary stuff you really
shouldn't go down there I don't tell me
what to do oh well I'm gonna shoot a
nanny you cuz I can't miss at this point
been bang with my moon thank you boo boo
ah ha ha all right all of you get kill
you guys
douche ah ah
you can't hit [ __ ] Wow yeah well Gary's
gone alright well that's okay because I
got this handled
watch as I handle this very slowly bang
oh you got bang a bang and here we got
bang okay you're dead
wait that do for me you've
single-handedly put a stop to the cult
activity of Buffalo pile impressive you
pretty much have the run of the place
now if you need aim bones for anything
you got a perk on you've secured access
to an unlimited supply of bones in case
you need bones for anything what does
that do me what good is having unlimited
bones what does that does for me okay
all right I'll take my bones I'm not
gonna complain I'm not gonna look a bone
horse in the mouth
I'll take this bone I don't know what
that does for me but supposedly around
hellström ranch is so oh hi
well if there's a sudden thrilling woosh
sound at a man dressed all in dark gray
with a long flappy coat and a grey
bandanna
it pulled up to conceal his face appears
before you either shadows he brandishes
a wicked looking knife at you accusingly
stop right there
prove your allegiance for all suffer no
cultists in this place could you be more
specific the necromancers cultists the
skeleton guys I'll show him I'll accuse
the accuser on a Hornswoggle yeah well
now wait a minute I'm not the one in the
dark cloak jumping out of people how do
I know you're not the cultists I killed
cultists with what that evil looking
knife cuz that's no cult II and that's
not culty at all no sir my tech know
there are own knives and use them
against them as poetic justice
so the masked stranger brandishing a
literal cult dagger at me as claiming is
an occultist hey this isn't about me
that's got you all right thank you sir
thank you for that thank you for that
thank you for that so any cultists
around here
cult d wall T Woo's may if I wander for
a bit some kind of crazy skeleton
charges at you from behind a rocky
outcropping Krum out krumping he's
crazier and crump er than most animated
walking skeletons you see because he's
got a buffalo skull for a head
oh it's one of these guys buffalo
tranquilize all buffalo skin pants
buffalo pants please don't come off
tonight it's cold
is that a reference or something you
have no idea also I just remembered
there's something else that I have to do
I have to go over to the fort of
darkness because I have the outfit too
with which to do though oh excuse me
could you just shoot nanny away and all
of them you hit one god damn it that
wasn't able to be able to point to that
all right fine you breathe through bad
breath all over me
alright but I got to go down to the
Florida darkness because the Dancy pants
people are in the tent over here and I
have not that I have I have Dancy pants
with which to do that so if I take off
an old sloppy toppy
for a second there I put on microphone
put on my uh my Kurt's futz pants bam
not spit soaked I do love my spit soaked
but you know that's just gonna have to
wait yeah it's really good ahh hurts is
still leading his students in the Rubik
workout routine
[Music]
hello power surges frui you have
unlocked true potential curtsey and
physique turns out that guy's on
something you really do feel stronger
sweet right well that was nice I don't
know if there was much of a long-term
point to that but hey I got 10 muscle
that's not not about where's but there
there it is ah my spits Oh pants I know
I know I probably got more with my
something skin pants I don't know
rhinoceros but uh no no no no no I'm
done in there I'm done I'm done with
that okay so I gotta find something here
I'm missing something I'm missing a good
ol something-something what am I missing
well there's no point in just mulling it
over forever I'm gonna go back to the
train and just see what I got horns for
what an ancient seaweed drape skeleton
is shambling towards you hissing and
moming uh-oh I guess we must be near the
beach hiss how do you determine where
the desert stops and the beach begins
hiss I don't really know how to tell the
difference between desert sand and beach
sand I'm gonna Hornswoggle you oh wait
oh my gosh are you Davy Jones hiss have
you all your albums can have your
autograph the skeleton scribbled
something onto a piece of paper for you
and then wanders off puzzled rainy Jane
was really underrated I got a damn
confuse skeleton scribbled its name on a
piece of paper for you barely its name
is neat Coolio
I'm gonna get on a train excuse me whoo
okay so I'm already here
so I already been through this [ __ ]
if I just popped down here this Goosby
know I just respects this wig suitably
come on welded shut [ __ ] but I've
already built all right that don't do
that to me good those key all right
scoot Aleeah doo doo doo de doo why is
it such a pain in the ass to get over
your okay I'm sorry I got that guy oh
yeah BAM whap whap whap what sorry
guess I got lost for a second there feel
better he rubs his jaw well yes and no
listen we're gonna get to Frisco but
first we need to bust into the locomote
up front and arrests a crazy guy I need
some volunteers okay I'm in I have to
sit here and do nothing for much longer
I'll probably flip out again cool all
right then
well Neto again but I don't ever woo
this is what it was oh I didn't even
need any thread oh you guys were
probably yelling at me oh I'm an idiot I
had everything I needed right away it
was to see horn squabbling okay lighter
lady I don't think you understand the
seriousness of this situation
Norton gets away with this his power in
Frisco will be limitless
the City Council won't be able to block
his horrible new tax increases tax
increases for instance well for a start
he's demanding a four thousand percent
price hike on yarn she gasps outrage bad
villain
we must subdue him immediately wash out
when I'm ready that's what it was I did
need something I am not that dumb
I needed an animal but I don't know
where to get that I'm suspecting there
might be something um there might be
something new and I believe there was
more to do in bread wood and I believe
it had to do with some other stuff going
to open it off give me that [ __ ] I
believe it had something to do with if
ghost would in bread would that I needed
to do I'll be right back doo doo doo doo
doo doo doo I mean I'm not going
anywhere I'm telling that to the other
people in the town I'll be right back
you know I told you to be right back
I'll go knock knock mr. Humperdink how
can be a service he's finally I'm here
on behalf of Mayor Brad would he needs a
permit to do some long games area I see
well there shouldn't be a problem I'll
just need to review the logging records
to make sure there are no disqualifying
incidents go to the Department of
Records it's two doors down and tell
them I need the bread would file
pertaining to logging is something wrong
not yet I'm just stealing myself in
anticipation wait she said two doors
down that doesn't make sense
hmm hello mr. Humperdink was it what can
I do for you I'm about to pick up a file
in the town of bread wood oh you want
the Department of Records next door this
is the adjunct Department of Records
ah thank you hello never mind
it's the stable apparently Department of
Records how can I help you mr.
Humperdink I'm supposed to pick up a
file on bread wood a moment please bread
wood apple wood anti-would bad what did
he mean bagel would know it's bread
would must be a suburb beaver would best
wood bit of wood but wood here where our
bread wood which section did you need
logging records hmm this section has
been downgraded from disuse you'll need
to pick it up from the adjunct
Department of Records next door of
course bring it back here when you got
it I'll put it in the official intern
department document read folder is that
really necessary absolutely you can't
transfer documents between departments
without an inter Department document
transfer folder so thankful great cool
hello can I get a file bread wood
well these pages are all loose I can't
give them to you like this what if they
blow away just taking the next door
they're giving me the document folder
it'll be fine
no no no no what if there's a freak gust
of wind as soon as you leave you're
chaos so what do you propose well
fortunately I happen to be the one
person in town authorised to officially
authorized to use a stapler to staple
them together for me I'd be glad to but
but I don't have a stapler
Kirsty don't don't worry all you have to
do is go next door to the department of
requisitions next door and requisition
one so I'll bring you a stapler and
you'll give me the file yep all right I
need the stapler requisition form last
name pumper dang first name mum Fleur
middle name both danger and marshal
danger what wasn't it I don't know I
can't remember anymore it's been so long
I just
Farber tink mom Fleur Paul
Oh Frick I don't remember what what's on
my ah
Frick what's on my identification oh god
it's such a nightmare
where is it where are you where the hell
are you there it is sneaky sneaky fine
bumper take mom Fleur sneaky desert
preference oh why does that have to do
with look I have two boxes one says cake
the other says pie I wanna have to put a
checkmark in one of them which is I'll
take I don't I only like pumpkin pie but
I like pumpkin pie more than I like cake
so I'll go with pie ah well despite that
everything seems to be in order
I'll get this file here's your stapler
Thanks oh okay all right I got you
stapler can I have the login report you
bet Kurt jump here you go fresh loose
Abel doing wind resistance I've got to
pick up the folder you splits carry it
in great cool great glad I'm doing this
a knock knock look at Abby I got the
paper
God okay I got a father oh great thank
you Whoopi do P I go over there ah
finalists have a look Oh for the love of
that idiot stapled the pages together
right in the middle this is why we took
his damn stapler away from him in the
first place this file is unreadable
you're gonna have to tell him to
unstable it great wonderful wonderful
administration wants you and unstable
these papers oh sorry I'm only a try
next oh I'm only authorized for stapling
not unstable and try next door at the
Department of Records I think they have
an unstable ooh there
newspapers unstable okay I'm fully
authorized to unsafely so that's no
problem
super did you well let's just say I
don't tell you see a staple remover
anywhere let's write the dye apartment
of libations borrowed it to open beer
bottles right do you have the staple
remover sure do that thing pops the tops
off a beer bottles like you wouldn't
believe
so long as it remove staples I'll be
happy I imagined it does but I'm afraid
I'm not authorized for unstaple when you
have to take it back over to records
here you are the ghost of a stapler
remover still looks like a weird metal
thing monstermouth except now it's and
goes for him now your office job is even
spookier here no I need to where I have
no idea where was I going again oh wait
that's right
you need to go back to the Department of
Records keep the stable of course
there's this table remover right let me
just up to his old tricks I see these
don't even need to be stable that's what
the end of Department document transfer
folder is all after after all all right
here you go
thanks screw us okay I'm back we're back
with an unstable bread boot files
alright let's have a look mmm ok I can't
see any problem with this I'm frankly
let's get started on the paperwork for
that logging permit I am no longer
amazed last name for dang first day mum
Fleur middle name sneaky CAD you need to
stamp this here kachunk and sign this
scribble and now you sign here sign
scribble also here sign and initial here
scribble scribble sign here scribble
good now you take this back to the mayor
of bread wouldn't have a sign online in
Israel over there are you kidding me I
don't know how to do that
oh okay it's fine
get out my way I need to go to bread
wood gotta get a bread would like right
meow yeah my face and let me go to bread
wood then we're not gonna have a problem
mayor can you sign this goddamn form I
think I need a ghost pencil for this of
course you do
sign down Aaron initial over there after
some fumbling with the ghostly pencil
the mayor eventually manages the sign
and initial to form all right mayor I'll
be back with that permit God willing
here we go back to ghost
whoo whoo all right I'm back I got is
the thing you wanted at this point I'm
not even sure well if this is worth it
all right knock knock hello mr. fun per
dink how can I be a service I've got the
mayor's signature on this logging permit
form great just sign the last bottom
behind the bottom where it says receipt
something wrong hello my pencil of the
mayor excuse me while I go kill
everything
ah ah okay
all right we got this everything's fine
everything's totally fine don't worry
about a goddamn thing
yeah my pencil Oh terribly sorry I think
it's haunting my beard ah here you go
sharp and goes pencil thank you
back to ghost Hornswoggle get the freak
out here you're a whole god goopy ax all
right I got it
sign all right that's everything taken
care of redwoods logging permit is
hereby approved processing will team you
can pick it up in two days
Wow excuse okay all right
well there was something else here that
I needed to take care of as you isn't it
I got your picture and I've got nope
I've got nothing for you
apparently all right I'm gonna end this
episode here before I lose my goddamn
mind so thank you everybody for watching
and thank you for joining me as I waste
my time let me know in the comments
below and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]